[Music]
life on earth emerged at least three and
a half billion years ago as prokaryotes
these are the simple unicellular
organisms they have a membrane on the
outside and a wash of cellular machinery
inside all mixed together and touching
and sharing the same environment this
worked
certainly life chugged along this way
for nearly half of the history of life
on Earth
but then 1.8 billion years ago something
remarkable happened something that led
to a tremendous shift in the scope and
complexity of life something we should
all be grateful for because without that
leap we would not exist cells
started to contain cells and this isn't
generally how it's talked about in
science class there you hear that
eukaryotes have quote membrane bound
organelles these are areas of the cell
that are separated from the rest of the
cytoplasm by membranes just as the cell
itself is separated from the rest of the
universe by its membrane it turns out
different activities require different
conditions and these cells within cells
allow for those different conditions
that in short is the secret of
eukaryotic success but how did it happen
well over decades of study we've
determined something shockingly peculiar
something so odd that it makes us kind
of mad that we now discuss it as if it
isn't the miracle that is 1.8 billion
years ago a cell consumed another cell
but then it didn't digest it it let it
reproduce inside of it and they lived
together and over time became the same
organism or did they this is what we
call endosymbiotic theory mitochondrion
appeared when the consumed cell was
adapted to live in an oxygen-rich
environment and chloroplasts appeared
when the swallowed cell was
photosynthetic this idea was deeply
controversial when it was first proposed
but as data have continued to come in
MgO symbiotic theory has been able to
explain more and more about the
realities we find for example that
chloroplasts have their own DNA which
they use to create the proteins required
for their function and as we dive deeper
into the micro cosmos
it just becomes obvious that this
happens
this is Paramecium bursar eeeh a
single-celled protozoa that has several
hundred algal cells from the genus
chlorella living in its own cytoplasm
making it green the algae live inside
Paramecium bruce arya providing it with
fuel in the form of sugar and other
substances produced via photosynthesis
and Paramecium bruce aria provides
protection for the algae from algae
eaters and viruses peeper Sariah is
regarded as a predatory protozoa it
feeds on bacteria small organisms and
yes algae and because of that it's often
thought that the algae in it are
temporary symbionts engulfed by
Paramecium burse areas feeding behavior
but in fact many other protozoa acquire
algae in that manner for temporary use
but that is not the case for peeper
Sariah its symbionts are continuously
inherited from generation to generation
through cell division the symbiotic
chlorella guide the Paramecium to
well-lit areas so they can
photosynthesize more efficiently and the
mutual relationship is extremely
beneficial for the Paramecium
even when chlorella containing
Paramecium cells are put in a nutrition
free saline solution they could survive
for more than three months while cells
that didn't have chlorella died within a
week
this is another single-celled organism
within december otic algae it's a test
state amoeba a kind of amoeba that
builds itself a shell this species like
some kind of sculptural artist pulls
bits and pieces of mineral from its
environment to create these amazing
looking homes you can see the amoeba
extending from the opening of the shell
and you can see the green algae in its
cytoplasm just like Paramecium burr
sarria the algae used sunlight to
produce food sharing it with the amoeba
while the amoeba provides protection
some unicellular organisms don't need
oxygen for growth indeed the presence of
free oxygen can affect them negatively
or even kill them these organisms are
known as anaerobes such as this one mat
opus it's an anaerobic Cillian we find
in pond sediment and it has an
endosymbiotic relationship with
nathanael genic archaea and we haven't
talked much on this channel about
archaeans but they are the third domain
of life along with bacteria and
eukaryotes and like bacteria they are
prokaryotic I can't wait to do our
episode on them someday soon many of the
single-celled eukaryotes living in
anaerobic environments contain symbiotic
prokaryotes some of these prokaryotes
are methanogens meaning they can use
free hydrogen to generate energy and
methane the advantages of having these
symbionts are not fully understood but
while Matt opus can live without this in
Vance they grow faster when they have
them
in december osis occurs in multicellular
organisms as well this is a freshwater
relative of jellyfish and sea enemies
Hydra
it's simply stuffed full of algal
symbionts we collected this Hydra from a
nearby pond and cultured it in our
aquarium the benefits provided by the
symbiotic relationship here have been
well-documented with scientists actually
tracking how carbon moves from the
environment into the algae and then into
the Hydra and studies have shown that up
to 69 percent of the caloric
requirements of the Hydra is satisfied
by its algal symbionts nice so we see
some organisms temporarily pull in
symbionts others passed them from
generation to generation some can
survive without them and some cannot
when we look at the algal cells in pee
verse area were forced to ask if those
cells are part of the organism or if
they're simply cells of one species
living in the cells of another if that's
the case it's worth asking whether the
mitochondria in you are you at all or if
they are just another extremely
successful species of prokaryote that is
particularly reliant on its host cell as
we look deeper and deeper down the line
between organisms is harder and harder
to find which is why if you think hard
enough you might begin to feel like our
cells are more than just ourselves
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds and inhabits us journey
to the micro cosmos is produced by
complexly which produces over a dozen
shows on YouTube including scishow and
we wanted to let you know that the
scishow team has just put out a really
interesting new episode this year of
course marks the 50th anniversary of the
first time humans walked on the moon and
to celebrate scishow made their first
documentary the team traveled throughout
the US I even went to the UK to talk to
experts trying to figure out whether the
moon landing was actually a good idea
and they got some really interesting
answers but I won't spoil them you can
watch the episode at youtube.com slash
scishow or by clicking that link in the
description if you want to see more from
our master of microscopes James check
out Jam and germs on Instagram and if
you want to see more from us that my
friends is what that subscribe button is
for
[Music]